يعني الفيديو الذي انتشر انتشارا كبيرا
وانت تحضر فيه الحليب لابنك وسط مجلس
رجالي اولا ما رايك بهذا التفاعل كبير مع
هذا الفيديو
من كميه التفاعل اللي صارت على المقطع
خصوصا مقطع كان بين اصدقائي يعني ما كان
المقطع
متوقع ان ينتشر بهذه الطريقه
همم المقطع كان بين اصدقاء انا حطيته في
تيك توك
وانتشر خذ انتشار ما اقدر تسيطر عليه يعني
حتى كنت ناوي احذفه في البدايه لان اا
الصوره اللي ناخذت على المقطع غلط يعني
احنا ما كنا في وسط المجلس همم اللي في
الكبار احنا كنا فيه زاويه شباب جلسه مع
بعض نضحك ونسولف الولد جاء جهزتنا الحليب
يعني الموضوع ما كان اكبر من
اه بس حسن يعني واضح عليك كثير مرتاح وانت
بتعد الحليب يعني كانه هيك مش اول مره
اسلوب حياه عندك انت من مناصرين مساعده
الزوجات وانه المراه والرجال واحد يعني في
تربيه الابناء
انا ما اعتقد ان الموضوع اننا جالس اساعد
همم الزوجه وقاعد اساعد همم احد انا قاعد
اساعد الولد في النهايه هو
بولدها هي بس
ما ساعدت حدانا غير ولديه